I revenge date is co-sponsored by the
digital humanities center here in by the
library and also smart Nepal at Lazarus
felled lecture series and and that
cereal I use their exact language and
celebrates Lazarus felts commitment to
improving methodological approaches that
address concerns and vital cultural and
social significance and so as great to
have dougs work included on that and and
so let me give you a little bit of
background on dead boys back with us he
was part of the faculty for our Summer
Institute last year and has been
involved with teak on a number of
different ways over the years so we're I
feel to have him here for the special
lecture and he now serves as the
director of the Louie B Nunn Center oral
history at University of Kentucky
libraries and he's currently directing
the Iowa last national leadership grant
owns enhancing access and discovery or
more on this day online and that's what
we'll be talking about tonight and we
recently managed the oral history in the
digital age project which I can say as a
professor of world history is sort of
the most important resource for anything
digital that you're trying to learn
about you're on the street is constantly
evolving and really a touchstone for a
lot of important conversations of the
field and I was a national initiative
exploring current best practices for
collecting and curating and
disseminating oral histories he recently
published a book crawfish bottom
recovering a lost Kentucky Community and
which was really path-breaking in that
it explored the use of archives where
all the streets in new context which is
something really where we always are
kind of oral histories and hope that
other people will come along and use
them but I think we don't off very often
think clearly and critically about that
process saying that I was really
important that duck did and he's also
the digital initiative
under the oral history overview and MA
and PhD our info for from Indiana and
Henry classy was his advisor which mode
would resonate with a lot of early
audience I think so I'll turn it over to
you thank you so much for coming and the
joy well thanks for nothing in passing
on time thank you for having me I'm the
you know the ohc a dog's community
relations project is also coming out as
the next special issue of the artistry
review so there's 14 articles which I
all-time high for your own history
review and not sure when that comes out
it's turned in which is a great relief
of stress for me but we're really a nice
you know because that takes it into the
scholarly conversation some of these you
know so it's not so much a how-to as
much as it's really sort of thinking
about or listening to Joe age
essentially from scholar perspective
which is really fun so that's my plug I
do have a plug village in the Julia
website
sense that in a way just to sort of set
up a disclaimer for myself it is a
wonderful sort of nexus for collecting
curating and disseminating oil industry
really the technical side you know it's
not how to it's really about in terms of
interviewing but it very much tried to
speak to if you came in early and you
heard me talking to the class you know
thinking through our history from a you
know and i'll reveal too much about
myself by saying is from a tall Grande
and venti structure because we have oral
history like the Shoah foundation with
an enormous budget and where this tree
lighting County Historical Society low
budget and and how can we write a best
practices or create a best practices
platform that that speak to and work for
both of those those entities I think we
really did a good job video question
which the video much of the video is
shot actually here at Columbia
downstairs means office sex right now
but so we have you know video interviews
with experts access over 200 best
practices the ask Doug thing is my
disclaimer I didn't call it that but you
haven't seen it I i do because i believe
in with how to record workshops for 10
years at the debate and so i get maybe
two hundred phone calls a year from
people saying what reporter do i buy and
so I told the process of determining
what the best reporter for you is
because there's I've narrowed it down to
21 questions that I essentially would
ask you if you called me and and so we
automated that so it's kind of like
eHarmony
you know you answer these questions I'm
going to match you up with your your
soul may record and what what it does it
actually work so so but I didn't want to
call it a step they played with that but
but again the idea is helping to empower
people to make decisions for themselves
how can we give you the kind of
information that's not just going to
have you memorized ok I need to record
at the standard but really help you to
understand why and empower even people
to see themselves as just interviewers
who need to know a little bit about the
curating side of things in order now the
digital age is really integrated of the
different processes and faces of world
history so it's really important so I
think about oral history a lot you know
using this you know because the tree
falling in the forest becomes
unavailable I just transferred over
windows this is a really cool animation
and we're Julie hard on it but the idea
of the tree falling in the forest you
know we're interviewing people in saving
these stories this is really great but
after years of being in the archives
what drives me nuts is we do these
interviews to click these individual
stories onto this Oracle record and what
drives me nuts is going to an archive
ooh my own archive and seeing interviews
that were conducted on cassette in 1974
with the best of intentions to get these
stories out there and they have sat on
the shelf until 2012 maybe two people
that fool these cassettes listen to them
that was not the original intention of
world history I think I think the idea
was no was was one that eventually not
every interview now he would be on the
internet and searchable and whatnot
that's might explain what for the rest
of the presentation but but but you know
eventually these interviews were
originally conducted for our access and
I go to repository and see and
collection of interviews with the roller
monitored is still on reel-to-reel no
backup and no machine on the facility
that facility to play back those
interviews and that's you know that I
think that that's something that
underlies my entire philosophy in terms
of an arguable approach and that's what
I'm sort of talking about here is an
epochal approach another disc later if
you get a 2 million dollar grant you can
do
lift pull of the street for a small
project for a fixed project you can do
such amazing things that you can hire a
programmer you can do amazing things but
what we've proven time and time again
are these one-off boutique projects
aren't sustainable in terms of in terms
of I've created myself unsustainable
tools the head that that that you know
now need a grant in order to bring them
back to life which is really sad and so
I think as we sort of emerging through
this new model of archiving we really
need to think about sustainability as an
underlying principle because this was
the model before the interview those
that use go into this box and the user
takes off work or comes in to you know
to your research room to listen to hours
and hours and that just doesn't you know
that's just not really the dominant
model for conducting research today for
better or worse and so from an archival
perspective on constantly thinking about
you know how we can serve these folks in
an effective and efficient way you know
not just throwing something up there you
know our collection catalog which this
is a thumbnail from you put it online
because 10,000 page views a month now
you know for an oral history collection
in Kentucky you know you google
analytics tell us amazing things about
who's using these collections and and it
really is remarkable and I've been
thinking a lot about this idea
triangulation and and its role in this
whole process and just to give you an
anecdote this this interview took like
four Gators already so i'm sorry but
this interview marshall web sister just
a world war two veteran who talks about
this experience he's interviewed back in
86 it's actually not a great interview
from a from a young technical standpoint
you know he doesn't remember a lot of
things and whatnot but it's also really
beautiful you both poetry about his
experiences as a better than he read it
on on in the interview well this is just
one of you know 500 or so they're just
have one or two veterans you know it's
got decent metadata so told you know our
catalogs getting 10,000 hits page view
the page views among his email last week
this is last week from a researcher in
Italy who is from this town tremon sweat
swelling general slowly and he had taken
a photograph there's a wall in this town
were signed by all of these Americans
you guys won't even see this the life he
connected this to this you said to me we
actually uploaded John we have loaded
the audio within like 20 minutes you
have the audio and had access just as
amazing key suspect it on flickr I
I was just trying to find a town so I
actually signed this the ACT had action
packet appropriately so I was able to
find this picture and I was like wait a
min google searches my hard drive
because i have a picture for the
powerpoint on my hard drive like Google
night this really moment of like
disconnects was like oh my god it's
unclear how that is what what if like
picture and then I realized that Sam
that that had uploaded so of this wall
were all these American GIs under name
he tracked it down from the sky he's
he's writing on all about this battle in
this small town so cool so you know the
idea of connecting that making that kind
of connection is really transformative
imagining that in the analog domain was
really almost unmatched I think to to
you know to make that kind of quick
connection like that I mean classic
example again is you know this another
what we're to better and talking about
his experience in Buchenwald liberating
what this was actually in my collection
even though I 500 veterans this is kind
of miscellaneous this is you know this
one little factoid that takes up many
seven minutes of this interview that's
that's kind of this lanes but the idea
that we can then connect see which are
foundations range of seven hundred
interviews just about Buchenwald
suddenly brings major significance to
the seven minutes in my collection you
know and that's where we'll talk about
our history appreciate to the choir when
I talk about the fact that you know it
could be just seven minutes in
that that resonates with your research
but your research is going to pull out
you know information from the 25th
minute you know and likewise and so the
idea being empowered today to be able to
connect people not just two interviews
but to Lois is really exciting and that
comes from a long period of struggle
letting for me from an archival
perspective of failing feel like I'm
failing at connecting researchers to
this content I'll tell you why we have
interview with 90,000 interviews saw
20,000 hours average 200 to 500 mil a
year last year about 800 now their state
regional national and international
topics in our collection when I took
over we had majority stowe analog with
very key transcripts created very
limited benefit does anybody interacted
with an archival collection or mystery
collection that has just collection
levels of data so you're interested in
civil rights and your you've got a
collection of seven hundred interviews
on some
the collection level description says
this interview contains if you read this
bunch of coins interviews about civil
rights movement in New York City good
luck you know I mean it really is like
saying hey I'm going to be in Berlin
over Thanksgiving hey me too I'll see
you there you know if you you know it's
the odds are against you and so so but
none of us have the kind of money from
an archivist am going to process things
and to transcribe everything very few of
us do and it's a time-consuming it's
cumbersome oral histories are really
cumbersome information package it's time
based it's hard to use as a researcher
because you have it's not if it's not
transcribed you can't search it so you
have to leave listen to it we're
watching you know and in this sort of
the culture that in which we live is
more and more expecting and demanding
efficiency and in search and discovery
thanks to google right I mean I get
maybe you know 3comments a month from
from patients are like when's the whole
collection give me a lot and I'm
thinking
but but I think there's the idea of
efficiency the idea of a massive amount
of information it's hard to describe an
interview from a metadata standpoint you
could spill it down but but its
necessary it's expensive obviously sorry
for the transition but we also have to
thank and we learn from the digital or
the stream digital age projects from
surveys and whatnot you know we're
thinking about this a lot in higher rep
because the people who are now coming
into our classrooms think very
differently than a lot of professors who
are teaching their courses myself I grew
up I've had an apple computer since I
was 12 but I had the internet and that
changes things in terms of a way that
people think these kids this is this one
here mastered the ipad within you know
seven minutes the operating system
understood how to use it the oldest one
I'll never forget this moment or my wife
Anna so it's not you know social
networking for kids is really kind of
creepy but they're coming out with these
toys that are integrated with social
networks just for you know a friend and
friend a real friend could friend a real
friend and then they can just interact
just two of them okay what is that toy
and say so just stuff down anyway not
not important for this talk you're
trying to make it work in my house
Charlotte's friends my wife can't make
it work Charlotte's friend is like a key
to my what says if you updated your
virginal Safari because it requires
originals
my wife just you know these kids think
differently than we do and we need to
think about how restructuring our
archives and not only that we need to
think about you know we need to think
about how we're structuring our archives
in our dissemination when we're
interviewing and when we're designing a
project because these projects are going
to be if they're if they're going to be
accessible they're going to be really
accessible in ways that me in this room
can't even imagine today in the next
five years and that's really exciting so
we developed spoke which is our online
catalog to solve the problem of metadata
it's got efficient ways to embed
metadata into the interviews in really
cool ways to optimize its getting this
but it's really usable in a very cool
way which is important because when
things aren't usable and I can't tell
you how many archival catalogs are
completely it's like they don't pay
attention to you know WebTrends you know
that searches funky in and it no this
generation expects amazon expects the
seamless search in google expects i want
to give the download something from
itunes and listen to it so you know as
we come back to this idea of you know
they want to search they want to explore
and we need to empower them to do so to
create situations like marshall webs
interview or to jump to from marshall in
center
from combat to Kentucky project and look
and be able to see that there are all
these wonderful your peace with
returning veterans from Iraq Afghanistan
brunette students so that this is the
problem is the online catalog is
institutional repository that freaks
people out putting this online I'm
telling you even my own students in my
graduate class like well I thought I
found the interview but I couldn't get
to it that's because it's not been
digitized yet you know this is the
catalog remember those you know I mean
really it's a really difficult thing to
convince them but she's going to expect
that so so we really have created sort
of portals to the digital objects and
I've been really exciting ways I think
you're able to and I have these three
different things that show up depending
on the way you're going to interact with
the energy when you come through our
catalog it's really Clark Alec
dynamically gives you a button that's
customized to letter the interviews been
transcribed whether the interviews been
indexed whether the interview is
searchable whether it's just browsing so
and that is really a direct correlation
to the fact that I've worked with
systems over the years that are just
funky and this is being recorded so i
can name any of them but digital library
digital library platforms were created
for photographs and for manuscripts they
fail miserably still at really
accommodating the needs of an old
history you know the idea of handling
time-based media that he
such a massive amount of metadata that
really is what a transcript is you know
really frustrated 7 so there's been some
really clunky approaches to that he also
i think the barrier of the transcript is
really important to point out to the
barrier of the transcript has been
really holding a lot of collections back
over the years hindi that we have to
transcribe it to make it efficient I use
this example a lot now because it's so
useful in demonstrating this that we
created this fancy system called ohms
and I'm about to show you we're about to
put it put an interview out from our
project with the Supreme Court justice
as you can imagine is that case law
being cited throughout sense of vs tells
us versus Ellenson this interview had
gone through our process of course it
was down to the process it was in the
digital pile that was labeled these have
been audited is somebody went through
and make sure this transcript the
spellings were correct and what not it
wasn't under my watch we inherited this
one but it was what supposedly went
through this process and my
undergraduate worker you know calls me
this is dr. Boyd elephant this is right
she's going through the final process of
syncing which isn't even listening to
the interview she's embedding time
coming into this transcript using Ohm's
and it's a landmark case maryland vs
virginia but the transcript said
maryland vs vagina
I'd like to think that the transcriber
didn't hear that that it was I think it
was a spell checker I think that whoever
audited were edited this transcript
actually caught a spelling and did an
auto correct and it was closer to a
giant western Virginia but when we think
about this burden that we carry in
transcription of perfection you know
because if i put it out there is a
transcript 75% may be larger amount of
researchers are going to copy and paste
the segment that they won't put it in
their research because if I'm branding
it as a nun centers transcript that's
its transcript that right that's what
they said and it's not even the most
vetted transcripts are flawed so I've
been trying to figure out you know how
we get past that how we make it more
effectively so when I drew lock the
initial schematic of homes and was sort
of just sort of thinking how do i want
the sort of seamless integration how do
I want to make sure that somebody's
interacting with the transcript they're
interacting with the world and their
hearing and we're watching that moment
and how can we just sort of create a
system to be able to do that and the
this is the original virtual went out
and it really was just transcript based
these are all three times in the field
that's okay so this was all transcript
based so then that transcript is you're
going through the idea behind the
original version was all like like us so
for where you're doing a search on
Felucia or will the video interviews for
our application veterans if you were
destroyed it proved so close our viewer
takes you through all the moments almost
like a PDF here now where you can
actually go through it but enemy takes
you to and it's on Fallujah worse than
is not on one and pretty confused this
makes as far as what's going on so
really as far as there's no magic and
close calls and everything when we
actually went into Fallujah Iraq in
terms of it's not it's not magic it
really was creating a video game-like
interface to take a transcript and drop
index points it very efficiently and
quickly so you only listen to ten
seconds on every minute and the bell
rings and you click an even better to
change a timecode you go to the next
minute bell rings you embed the time
code and it's a very efficient way to
drop time code into a transcript and
horses and researcher to the force but
encourages highly the researcher makes
it as easy as we possibly can to a find
the information they're looking for but
be corroborated with the original you
know with the report
so which is very important today after
watching all these trends so there's a
problem with that model and you know I
you know put it on the Kentucky digital
library 79 in interviews we uploaded
using about 600 that were transcribed
there 730 there now the problem is that
else is only hours and the transcripts
were so expensive so i created this
thing the conduct Kentucky's kind of
unique in the sense that we do have all
over the state or mr. activity because
we have something called the bureau's
permission the Kentucky digital library
allows them to put their interviews
online anybody else could have used ohms
during the last three years but nobody
did because it required a transcript and
I got to thinking about that I haven't
doubted that one underwater right during
the recession and I'm thinking you know
what I can't actually put ambassador for
twenty thousand dollars as a
transcription this year so what can we
do to sort of solve that all in the note
then there's the idea that keyword
search ability is not the Holy Grail
it's not perfect it's great to have
don't get me wrong I love it but
somebody can talk about segregation for
three hours how I've ever mentioned over
in segregation so you're looking to your
research and segregation what you have
to type in water fountain plus you know
you know people don't use public
accommodations
everyday speech unless they were a civil
rights activist so in terms of what i've
seen so so I think struggling with that
idea of how do we do that about this you
go to the grocery store and you see
where the Cheerios what are they going
to tell you I I'll 10 I whatever the
record stuff right then what no I don't
really know where the Cheerios known
over the Cheerios are the great don't
grab your hand walk you down you know
turn of the right I'll walk you down 117
paces turn you set your head at a 45
degree angle because you're only five
foot six and and reach out and help you
grabbed up this time I'll ten you the
smart human being go find aisle 10 and
then when you're in Aisle 10 I'm putting
to you you're going to get into out of
10 you're going to go look for a while
the picture of the Cheerios now I didn't
know they actually certainly lose heart
bangle that's really appropriate for
today happy Valentine's Day to everyone
but you look for the yellow box you look
for the O's right smart people we you
know use language signs and symbols and
and what not to find this the idea is
could we do that your history interview
in an efficient way that was effective
for the user with that point of the cost
of that so starting to do indexing and
introducing with indexing module into
homes cut my costs by a tenth I can
index an interview for forty dollars
paying an undergraduate or graduate
student to do that work as opposed to
four hundred dollars which is one of the
cost of transcribe that's in there
indexing really allows you to use
controlled vocabularies like to solve
the segregation and mapping the natural
language to solve that segregation issue
that that you know somebody is talking
about segregation you can actually
basically catalog that moment and say
you know they're using these words but
what they're talking about is this so
creating a sort of mapping of natural
language uses an advantage of indexing
Holmes allows you now to link out to
things GPS coordinates and whatnot which
is really cool and integrates with
google maps and such but but i like that
i like the integration of both but
engaging community tonight we're going
to talk about this a person i want to
show it so
yeah so the search for a the front end
tells you every second that we talked
about Marines in that's just Josef Tiger
gate hard to see that ma h equals f er
that's Jacob I don't want to listen to
me I want to talk about his transition
home entire education like your tables
battle and this rock out this is what's
really exciting to me because I can now
take an interview and enhance access to
it for a fraction of the price and what
I have found is I didn't design it for
this reason what i've found is the best
people you know to who's got a cooler
mystery project not Iran is you in too
many who once so what's your glorious
your project yeah all right right so
we're the best people to index those
interviews a bunch of graduate students
in Kentucky New Yorkers right so I give
you a password as a project director you
can sit on your back porch with drinking
a latte and index an interview so
instead of transcribing your interview
which we none of us want to do or paying
a transcribed interview which one of us
can do Lana's can't do you can go in and
tagged
moments I mean if you're researcher and
you're going to mine these four for
dissertation or a book or documenting
you have to do this anyway so why not
take notes in the system that that tag
those notes to those moments so what I'm
doing now is structuring projects where
we're actually engaging communities in
curates curating of these interviews so
it's not true crowdsourcing you have to
go through my sort of training program
on indexing but when the oldham county
historical society gives us a series of
interviews to put in our repository it's
the Oldham County communities that's
going to do the better index of those
interviews and so I I teach them to do
that it's suddenly more engaging
communities on whole new level of one of
the street before engaging community in
all this tree meant interviewing period
now you're actually engaging them in
disseminating curating these interviews
now is it perfect model no absolutely
not but again we're not holding the
interviews hostage to perfection and
with that transcript we're able to get
these out and the ideal scenario for me
is you know to solve the transcriber
index today by having both toggle over
so you want to go deeper and the same
search on the transcript and wow you can
go to that moment so the third component
that we're going to add to that is to
have basically a second transcript /
translation so if you have a
multilingual interview which more and
more of us are in terms of archives are
being able to
ladies you can have a bilingual index or
a bi-level transcript that's not even
done it yet so but both of which will be
synced in search of one which is really
excited we're going to start putting up
somewhere he should Creole interviews
with survivors of the haitian earthquake
in 2010 in this system and I'm really
jazzed about it so so that I think
really brings me to sort of solving some
of those problems of mine it's still a
manual process right so the dream of
automatic speech recognition is highly
flawed by the fact that we can do really
nice work using speech recognition
technologies on a perfect recording with
someone who has no accent so we can do
I've seen it systems that will do I know
a guy who designed a system that does
CNN and al-jazeera and we'll just just
just shy of real time with about ninety
seven percent accuracy those people have
no accents they've been taught to strip
their accents out completely the
recordings are perfect environmentally
the microphones are close and there's no
background noise and so you take that
same system down to Harlan County
Kentucky and I'm recording from the
1970s and it will fail it would be more
it will do more harm than it does good
and so right now so this is sort of a
new war club there's partial automation
it makes things efficient into allowing
you to encourage you to use controlled
vocabularies and ads in the community
engagement perk I think which is
which is really empowering my dream well
first I won't take him everywhere the
grant that I managing is actually
cooking homes up you know it's going to
open source it's going to be free that's
the other thing is this is being given
away so the moment I can actually
distort the society can use something
like this if they have web space problem
with open source is a lot of times open
source means you need to make a free
beach in your program and so the idea is
not to have that so we're cooking ohms
up out of the box as a plug-in for some
of these common platforms that are some
of the most common platforms do really
using for digital archives so we saw a
great demo here from the posi where's
the digital humanities center here did a
grateful for students opinions on that
guy once it's going to be a plug-in
romantic so instantly transform with a
wedding in two incredibly sophisticated
platform for delivering oral history but
down to a simple website that's posted
on Drupal which is really common web
site management platform now contentdm
is one of the more common library
digital library systems that really
struggle to grow this tree and it
doesn't integrate the transcript the
audio or video are all separate and it's
a very difficult process so the other
thing that sort of underlies my whole
philosophy is I've been in systems that
I've been stuck in and not able to get
my own content
and so I've been burned by that many
times and so the idea is the gnomes
there are really super fancy systems out
there that allow you to markup and
annotate audio video but they don't work
with other systems typically and they're
not very interval and so the idea of the
homes is it exports an xml file period
that's it the viewer reads that xml file
but whatever repository you are using in
the world you just have to have that XML
50 XML is something that is every
computer now reads that's being used is
something that you could actually save
your XML as a CSV reach again in Excel
or open up the XML made it yourself on
on a browser and so the data is north
and so the idea was to create something
that didn't require Owens to work
because I was might not be here in five
years so if you go to the work and
trouble to index and timecode sink and
do all of the stuff you should be able
to take that to any system you want and
so the export that you're creating
emphasis is something that is very much
geared towards interoperability it's
open source because I'm not going to be
able to provide twenty four seven
support you know I don't have a call
center where you're going to be able to
sort of do that
is that the community is going to to
really take that into hopefully adopted
as being adopted in terms of initially
by the Grand partners but the people who
are interested in it really it's really
exciting mix so now we're talking about
connecting our users to our histories
they're discovering our stuff but then
they're they're not just discovering it
very it's a sort of work with it this
generation I won't show you more
features of my kids that this generation
wants to take the stuff from work with
it and you all want to work with it mess
around with it mash it up with something
else and I think it's really important
that on the archive site that we
actually step up and and create a
platform that encourages that
responsibly but also effectively and
efficiently and really exciting things
are happening right now has solved a lot
of these problems but with the automatic
speech recognition which I get asked a
lot about their zone where people AO
started to show you is this interview
but I did it pass on Elmer Tilly's
interview using speech recognition and
then I took that nasty transcript that
was probably about fifty percent based
on just a cursory look got about a fifty
percent right now I almost got a pretty
heavy southern accent but still fifty
percent is pretty low if you try to pass
the office of transcript that still is
in the range that's going to create more
work for you to fix than to just
transcribe the thing yourself if you
don't call the transcripts what if we
call that
and we don't show to the public we make
it searchable and put it behind an index
so i did a text mining data word count
analysis on the automatic piece of the
work piece of the big words i filtered
out the columns in the house and the
Elmer's and those things when filtered
all those out now if i take an archivist
off the street with them that at that
interview and Isaac come up with your
subjects and keywords and catalog this
interview talk about plant bourbon
people taste were talking about the
business of bourbon we're talking about
warehouses tasting brands distiller
that's actually pretty good depiction of
what's actually in that interview of
course you can do cool things like the
word game but you know suddenly you as
an artist just head back to look at in
order to describe the interview based on
automatically generated transcript it's
pretty close to making that interview
process and searchable in a pretty
efficient way so I come back to this
idea of designing our systems our
workflows to to to to serve this sort of
digital model and expectations and when
I come back to this example I'm thinking
about it all day for the last two days
and the Marshall web you know I started
indexing interview today I talked to the
guy who did
back in 86 and it's really you know it
really symbolizes to me what it's all
about you know he's taking not just the
individual story but taking the segment
within that story and actually suddenly
exploding it you know or just sort of
completely empowering that moment with a
whole nother set of meeting now in terms
of public history in this potential so
so as we sort of go through i do want to
open the floor up for questions enough
time for that so so that's kind of homes
it's kind of what we're working on in
terms of trying to enhance access to it
and really create empower users to
create a connection with oral history
are there any questions comments
suggestions